the climax of Avengers ends game
featured the death of a legend but it's
perfectly heroic as the moment was it
could have gone dozens of different ways
in a recent conversation with Collider
the film's editor Jeff Ford went in
depth about how the scene where Tony
Stark sacrifices himself to snap Thanos
and his invading army out of existence
came to be it's a fascinating deep dive
into the genesis of an unforgettable
scene and also an interesting and
humorous look at Downey's process Ford
is the longtime editor for endgame
co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo and
he's made himself a Marvel icon with one
contribution to the Infinity saga
culminating film it was he who put stars
last words into his mouth when he
suggested that the armored Avengers
retorts a thunderous declaration in him
should mirror the statements he made to
the world at the conclusion of the
inaugural entry into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
[Music]
it was perhaps the single greatest
moments in the MCU up to this point but
that's according to Ford
nobody was exactly sure how it should
play out and the time came to actually
shoot the scene since they were working
with a gifted actor and brilliant
improvisor in downey the filmmakers
basically decided to let him off the
chain and see what would happen
Ford told Collider when we were putting
together the end of the movie when we
shot Tony's last moments we shot a bunch
of different options Roberts had
different ideas we gave him space to do
that Joe and Anthony a great about
improv we shot a run of different
performances for that last moments some
of them were crazy some of them we would
never have used of course like everyone
else
the interviewer wanted to know more
about those crazy left-field takes that
never could have made it into the movie
but four declined to get too specific
citing a desire not to quotes he'll back
the curtain on Downey's process too much
but what he did have to say sound some
brands for our DJ of course it makes us
love the actor even more for dished some
of them with jokes some of them are
obscenities some of them were completely
emotional raw insane things that he was
doing and some of them were combinations
of all three of those things
that is so easy to picture from Downey
that were actually perfectly content to
let our imaginations run wild we're sure
some of these stakes were even crazy
enough to have worked but we're glad we
got the iconic moment that we did and it
was all thanks to the filmmakers wanting
a sense of symmetry
paralleling Starks lines of Thoreau says
I'm a navigable line interestingly the
only other version of the scene that the
filmmakers liked nearly as much as a
final one didn't involve any alternate
versions of the dialogue it actually
featured no dialogue at all Ford
explained in one version Thanos and
Stark who didn't say anything Thanos had
the gauntlet he looked at him like I got
you snapped looked couldn't believe it
turn to Tony tony raised his hand and
snapped it was beautiful it worked
really really well the filmmakers
realized however that they had an
opportunity to cement the themes of
their film and the arcs of the two
characters involved in the climactic
showdown when they'd landed on the final
exchange Ford said what we found was
such needed an arc an endgame that
was a sense of inevitability the story
we've been telling the South thanos says
pitch in that movie is they matter how
many times you try and stop me you can
travel in time you can do all these
things you're never going to win it's
the sense of destiny of I will always be
the one who wins Ford went on to say
that by having Thanos invoke that sense
of Destiny at the crucial moments only
two meters two feet the filmmakers drove
home the truth theme of endgame that
destiny will always land on the side of
right this is the fight of our lives and
we're going to win
whatever it takes it's interesting to
think about how many ways the climax of
ends game could have played out and if
we had gotten a different version it's
just possible that we would be hailing
that choice as the only one filmmakers
could possibly have made but we think
pretty much every Marvel found agrees
that the scene we got was utterly
perfect due in no small part to the fact
that it's tough to imagine a more
fitting parting shot for an actor who
completely embodied his character for
nine films and 11 years check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]